all our work is gone Ultron cleared out
use the internet as an escape badge he's
been in everything files surveillance
probably knows more about us than we
know about each other he's in your files
he's in the Internet but if he decides
to access something a little more
exciting nuclear codes nuclear codes
look we need to make some calls assuming
we still can nukes he said he wanted us
dead he didn't say dead he said extinct
he also said he killed somebody there
wasn't anyone else in the building yes
there was
this is insane Jarvis was the first line
of defense he would have shut Ultron
down it makes sense no Ultron could have
assimilated Jarvis
this isn't strategy this is rage
well it's going around come on you two
works but I have more than enough words
to describe you Stark or the Legionnaire
trail went cold about a hundred miles
out four it's headed north and it has
the scepter now we have to retrieve it
again genies out of that bottle clear
and present is Ultron I don't understand
you built this program why is it trying
to kill us you think this is funny no
it's probably not right this is very
terrible is it so oh it's it is it's so
terrorists could have been avoided if
you hadn't played something you don't
understand I'm sorry it is funny it's
who did you don't get why we need Tony
maybe this might not be the time really
that's it
you just roll over show your belly every
time somebody snarls only when I've
created a murder bot we didn't we
weren't even close when we close to an
interface well you did something right
and you did it right here The Avengers
were supposed to be different than she
anybody remember when I carried a nuke
through a wormhole no it's never come
save New York never heard that
recall that a hostile alien army came
charging through a hole in space we're
seeing the 300 feet below it worthy
Avengers we can bust arms dealers all
the live long day but that up there
that's that's the endgame how are you
guys planning on beating that together
we'll lose
and we'll do that together too
doors right Ultron's calling us out and
I'd like to find him before he's ready
for us the world's a big place start
making it smaller
you